hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our journey
on the Paul Morphy saga it's the first
American chess Congress and Morphy
successfully defeated his opponent in
round one and now he goes into round 2
where he faces a politician judge a
lawyer well you know a pretty strong
chess player
Alexander bow for the meek and well he's
a bit stronger than Thompson in round
one as you'll see by his moves and I
just wanted to mention that we discussed
that Louis Paulsen played a four player
simultaneous exhibition blindfold with
Murphy one of the opponents and he he
won the exhibition but he lost the
Murphy but then gained ten days some 10
maybe 11 days after that exhibition he
made a 5 a 5 player blindfold exhibition
where he won four and a half to half so
he won four games and only drew one
which was world record at the time in
blindfold games I just wanted to mention
that as I don't know if we'll be
returning to that so really really well
really nice game hope you enjoyed let's
dive straight into it so Nick opens with
E for we have E 5 buy more feet Knight
to f3 nights the c6 and Bishop to b5 me
goes for the real Lopez and Murphy goes
for Knight to f6 the Berlin defense even
though in those days it was it wasn't
called the brilliant defense with d3 I
moved that's perfectly fine today Bishop
to c5 by Murphy and c3 now we these six
by morphine so the game up until now is
probably the same as you would see
between two grandmasters in 2020 and
here the most common move is castles
nowadays but here b4 by meek and already
nowadays you you will not see a move
like this but okay be better back to b6
with a four at preparing a5 to trap more
fees Bishop and more if you just place a
sex makes room for the bishop kicks away
the light square Bishop Bishop back to
c4 and also after this h6 move move
seven disposition has never been reached
again so Mishra back to c4 and now
Bishop to e6 notice that it's not the
same idea as Thompson tried against
morphine
in game 3 of their match because then
yes Thompson didn't get the open F file
but his his double D pawns were were
very weak here if if for example this is
captured and captured which which it
which was played captures captures now
Morphy whenever he wants to play d5 he
will have and he he will have support
for when he decides to push it so
castles a Morphy also castles not more
he has the semi open file for his rook
and now Knight to g5 me goes for the e6
pawn he prepares King to h1 and also
makes room for f4 that's why Knight to
g5 Quinta East 7 defending d6 pawn and
now King to H 1 you have to unpin first
before going f4 we have h6 morphe
doesn't allow it he wants to kick back
the knight to f3 and here Knight to f3
really is best really is the way to go
but Nick decides to go for Knight to h3
he really wants to play this f4 move and
ok Murphy says we're not allowing that
we're just gonna push d5 put pressure on
white center the thread is just to
capture the pawn here as it's attacked
twice by the pond in the night and here
bishop the a3 Nick tries to trick Murphy
he wants more feet to play something and
then b5 attacks both the knight and the
Queen so you'd probably have to move the
Queen then you lose the the rook the
knight to the the game so more if it
goes back Knights to d8 he prepares the
block block this Bishop after b5 is
played and here there really is no need
to push be fog right away as it doesn't
really do anything so if you just
continue developing 92 and so on but me
decides to do it anyway probably I
thinking that it you know it's it's not
no harm has been done for example if c4
then you can just capture on Poisson and
still you have this very nice threat but
more if you of course blocks with the
bishop just Bishop to c5 and here again
meek goes Bishop to b2 which is odd if
you already played this you should just
allow this trade or something or or or
leave the tension I mean there's no
actual threat of you losing anything
okay you can't start developing good
night here because the bishop hangs but
there are some moves that can be played
you can
continue with f4 which was your main
plan all along or you can even capture
for example captures captures and then
go something d4 its playable let's say
Quincy four and then after takes black
takes here and it's it's still a game
morpheme or feels better but you could
you could play this
however Bishop back to be two he has a
different idea
now comes D captures an e4 by Murphy now
creating this triple pawns but now D for
this this was mix idea that's why he
wanted the bishop on b2 to keep control
of the d4 square e capture son d4 seek a
person d4 and Bishop back to d6 and here
at mix says okay you're up upon but it's
a doubled e pawn not really not really
worried about that and now he continues
development Knight to c3 and he's not
wrong okay black is better but you know
he works with what he has we have a
capture son b5 buy more feet a capture
some b5 and now of course not wanting to
trade to allow the activation of the
queen's own knight of seven here more if
he wants meek the capture so morphing in
capture on a eight and meek once the
same so queenie to he wants more fee to
capture so he can capture with the rook
but now Queen to d7 and it's it's a very
good move by Morphy the thread is Knight
captures on e4 from each side so Queen
to d7 saying if you capture I'm gonna
capture and after captors I'm just gonna
capture your beat b5 point which will
create a nice past beep on for myself
and here meek again went too quickly
with the capture he played Knight
captures on e4 he should have tried to
make more if you work a little bit
harder for his meal with something like
rook a b-1 maybe and then if Queen
captures at least you have a nice rook
on d1 or maybe even b6 just you know
spoiling more of his plans yes he can
play c6 but then the point survives or
he can capture and then he again has to
worry it's still doubled beep on so it's
not as potent to now you can capture
here and the game continues with more if
he still being up upon that it's a
double beep on so maybe a little bit
easier but he goes for it right away
captures captures we have Queen captures
on e4 and now Queen captures on b5 and
only now rook a to be one which kind of
is a bit dangerous but
with this queen being here like that not
not really
the bishop doesn't have any good
discoveries so just Queen to d5 here me
is kind of hoping to win back the pawn
but morphe says okay I enjoy attacking
but also someone gives me a pawn I'm a
pretty good and getting player myself
I'm just gonna play Queen d5 or a queen
trade and if you trade Queens
like I said characters captures there
aren't any decent discoveries to go
after the point here is Bishop c3 just
look at fb8 now you can start pushing
the beep on you can even play and be six
followed by c5 create the two connected
passed pawns a lot of ideas here for
black
so instead Queen back to g4 by meek and
now more if he goes look to a four what
idea is that now he can jump in with the
night he can play e5 as the points pin
you cannot move the pawn so here mix
said okay I'm just gonna go Knight to f4
which either you you're gonna give your
strong Bishop here or I'm attacking your
Queen and after you move maybe actually
and maybe I can capture on e6 which
would be excellent for me now but here
morphe says yeah that's that's not a
great move so feel free to pause the
video and try to find why morphe thought
that this wasn't a great move while i
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to use
congratulations unsporting that you can
attack the knight twice and also that
the Queen and g4 is undefended so for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its Queen to e4 and here white can
easily resign because he loses the night
you can defend it with g3 due to the pin
you could defend it with Bishop to c1
this is what meek played but it hangs
the rook and here he he wants more free
to capture the rook for example if
Murphy captures roof Knight captures
here then he threatens mate now however
g5 is perfectly fine and now let's say
Knight captures on f8 Morphy has even a
route k1 threatening to give up the
Queen for a nice background mate
so g3 making some room for the king but
now Bishop captures on f8 and white
really has no compensation for that for
the sacrificed piece so it wouldn't be a
rook it would be a knight because later
you grab the exchange but still morphe
doesn't bother with capturing the rook
and here he is somewhat similar to
Capablanca later
he doesn't feel like calculating this he
just plays a different move which is
just as winning he plays Bishop captures
on f4 and now he says okay if the Queen
captures then I'm gonna capture the rook
and then you don't have any I mean it's
just I'm just upper rook there's no
point in playing this so Mik played
Bishop characters on f4 which now the
rooks are defending each other but here
just recap for sandy for and here
there's no defending the bishop whatever
you play you're just gonna lose it still
you can play g3 because of because of
the pin and there is nothing more to be
done here so here you could resign me
for some reason place Queen to h3 made
one more move and then more features
captured on f4 and it was in this
position then I'm 29 that Alexander
Belford meek resigned the game and a win
in game 1 of round two goes to Paul
Morphy so Murphy still on 100% and
really really playing playing some good
chess but I really enjoyed that not
capturing the rook
when Mika offered it has a really
reminded of of Capablanca how he would
off often you know play a simpler move
because it's just this winning and
requires less calculation but yeah I
really really really cool stuff and if
you're interested this game lasted less
than an hour so Mick played fairly fast
and more fitted as well so they didn't
take a lot for them to finish this game
and also I prepared something for you I
just don't think I prepared the photo so
it just give me a second for me to to
load up the photos as it's quite
interesting okay there's that and the
one more there's the one yeah this is
the one okay so sometimes during round 2
all the players were invited at the st.
Denis Hotel in New York some of you may
know this hotel if ur from New York or
maybe if you visited New York it's it
was quite a landmark it no longer exists
I think it was a taken down maybe two
years ago or something like that I
checked on Google but it really had a
lot of history this is this is the hotel
I'm talking about
there you have it I'm just gonna make it
smaller so this is this is a this is the
hotel it was as you can see the st.
Denis hotel it was on the crossing of
Broadway and East 11th Street just south
of Union Square in New York City and it
like I said it had a lot of history now
let me just make it a little bit smaller
like this I had a lot of history for
example ulysses s grant wrote his
post-civil war memoirs in this hotel and
also Alexander Graham Bell provided the
first demonstration of the telephone to
New Yorkers in this hotel and not only
that the players were invited to this
hotel by their by the proprietor of the
hotel damaged julienne hence the name
st. Denis hotel and they were invited
and it was really the greatest chess
party like that that ever existed they
had chess songs they had all the food
was decorated you know in a chesley
fashion and they had like little napkins
with chess pieces they had tablecloths
with with chess ornaments they even had
meals and the dishes named after them so
here is one of the name of one of the
dishes that was named after morphe so if
any of you let me just move the photo
for a bit if any of you speak French
this is the meal that had more fees
names so if any of you speak French
maybe you can translate this for us in
the comments below so we can just enjoy
it I'm gonna pin pin your comment if
someone translates it so everyone can
see I tried Google translating it but
Google just doesn't make any sense of
this
I guess it's French I mean it doesn't
look like French so I hope it is so if
any of you can help out with that India
they had they had a lot of fun there I
had a lot to drink
you know they sang songs about how great
their base basically was a bunch of rich
dudes congratulating themselves on being
awesome and you know they sang songs
about it so and they agreed that this
whole American chess congress should be
a yearly event and a lot of a lot of
stuff like that so really awesome stuff
and yeah I just wanted to mention that
yeah this is the same Dennis hotel and
it was taken down as it although it had
a very long history it it wasn't
registered in the life like a historic
landmark in New York and that's why it
was allowed to take it apart and this is
the building that took its place
this is the one that took the place of
saint-denis I'm not I don't know if it's
already built but this is the building
that should have been built I don't know
if this is just a rendering or the
building is actually there maybe someone
else can also confirm this if you are
from New York but yeah I just wanted to
mention that and yeah that was that was
a game one I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Robert Garcia a
Wayne gardener Thomas Landowski Terry
Walters and Joseph Bessette for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the morphe saga
continue to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chests world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend